le chemin du retour au pays s'est
transformée en impasse piégée à la
frontière colombienne des familles
vénézuéliennes attendent depuis
plusieurs semaines espérant de l'aide
pour rentrer chez elle ces dernières
vivent dans des camps de fortune sans
solution voyez ici ce sont les
conditions que nous avons tous lu devons
nous mêmes nous aider les uns les autres
à nettoyer nous avons des enfants
malades et nous devons d'une manière ou
d'une autre
chercher une solution mes pieds me font
mal maman j'ai faim maman je ne peux pas
le supporter je veux rentrer je veux
rentrer à la maison la voir un enfant
dire ces choses et douloureux parce
qu'un adulte peut le supporter mais un
enfant n'est pas responsable de tant de
choses des enfants dorment à même le sol
dans des conditions sanitaires
déplorables
ces migrants sont étroitement surveillés
par les forces de l'ordre pour empêcher
tout débordement
nous parlons du fait que du début de la
ligne à la fin il doit y avoir environ
3000 personnes par les 500 qui sont
partis aujourd'hui lundi mercredi et
vendredi ce sont les trois jours choisis
par le gouvernement vénézuélien pour
ouvrir la frontière à ses ressortissants
mais le passage est restreint seuls 100
personnes par jour sont autorisés à
pénétrer de l'autre côté le président
vénézuélien nicolás maduro a annoncé le
déploiement des forces armées pour
empêcher les passages par des couloirs
non-officiel une décision critiquée par
carlos valero députés d'opposition
dans ces conditions inhumaines les
vénézuéliens se retrouvent dans les
lieux publics de coucou tas après
n'avoir pas pu entrer au venezuela par
les postes frontières que le régime
maintient désormais fermée ce qui
provoque le chaos et génère des
problèmes plus importants pour les pays
voisins des restrictions à la frontière
qui entraîne une réduction de près de
80% des retours selon les services
migratoire colombien plus de 70000
vénézuéliens ont quitté la colombie
depuis le début de la pandémie